the left truly believes that threats and
intimidation and violence
are going to win the day for them
over the weekend on sunday a number of
pro-abortion lunatics were disrupting
masses
we're going to catholic churches around
the country
one group of these lunatics put on some
handmaid's tale outfits and showed up in
a
catholic mass at the cathedral in los
angeles
[Music]
[Music]
the symbolism here is actually perfect
because these
wackos have showed up during communion
so this is
the holiest moment of the mass when the
the priest is consecrating the host and
he's saying
repeating the words of christ this is my
body which will be given up for you and
catholics believe that at
that moment the bread the bread and the
wine is transformed uh through
transubstantiation
into the literal body and blood of
christ so that so that god is in a very
tangible way with you in the room this
is my body which will be given up for
you and and the pro-abortion activists
bust in there at this extraordinarily
sacred moment of the mass
and they
ironically
invert
the message they say no this is my body
and you're gonna
your body little baby it's actually my
body and your body is gonna be given up
for me this is my body peter craft the
philosopher made this point he said the
way that you know that abortion is the
sacrament of the antichrist
is that
even the the sloganeering for it is is
the same it's the same wording of the
eucharist itself but with a
blasphemously inverted meaning this is
my body that's the chant that you're
hearing all over the place but instead
of a man giving up his life for his
friends one man dying so that all may
live
you have you have the opposite you have
people sacrificing their own children
just for their own desires just for
their what they what they think will be
for their own benefit actually actually
will not be for their own benefit but
they don't they don't understand that so
they're willing to do the pro-abortion
activists are willing to do just about
anything nothing
is too sacred for them to disrupt no
norm no standard is is to be held so
highly in esteem that they're not going
to violate it of course that's what i
said when when the supreme court opinion
leaked i said of course they leaked the
opinion these are people who kill babies
of course they're going to leave they
don't care about a supreme court norm or
standard if you're willing to kill your
child you're willing to do just about
anything so what do we do about this
the reaction so far generally speaking
from law enforcement has been hands off
just like outside of sam alito's house
oh well
yeah it's against the law to
show up and intimidate judges and try to
change their opinion but hey let's all
just let's just be cool right we're not
going to arrest anybody well that's what
they're doing here at this mass but what
those protesters did is illegal it is
illegal to do that
it's ironic because there's actually
it's a provision of a pro-abortion law
that actually protects churches from
these lunatics it's the freedom of
access to clinic entrances act of 1994.
prohibits the use or threat of force or
physical obstruction that injures
intimidates or interferes with a person
seeking to obtain or provide an abortion
that same law also to appease the
pro-lifers when this was being passed
uh also prohibits people from doing all
those things to exercise the first
amendment right of religious freedom at
a place of religious worship so what
those wackos are doing is illegal and do
you know what we should do there's two
opinions on this
the squishes and the nice guys they say
hey let's just let it go let's just let
them well do their thing that's silly
and then we'll just kind of ask them
politely to leave no arrest them arrest
them this has gone on way too long we
have let this go way too far if you want
if you want to stop a
perverse and disordered behavior you
need to punish that behavior okay
and and this is really bad for our civil
society it's really bad for a system of
law you need to arrest these people and
throw them in jail and teach them a
lesson naughty naughty no showing up and
screaming and disrupting mass naughty
naughty no terrorizing
brett kavanaugh's children or samalito's
family or any naughty naughty you're not
going to do that anymore and if you do
we're going to arrest you and if you do
it again we're going to throw you in
jail for longer i'm so glad you liked
that clip now
ring that smash that bell ring that like
click that subscribe make sure you get
all the notifications also head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
for free can you imagine and get the
michael knowles show leave a five star
review we will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]